aus Berlin ist mir jetzt Gustav gressel
wie eben angekündigt zugeschaltet er ist
Militärexperte beim European Council on
forign relations guten Abend Herr
gressel schönen guten Abend Herr gressel
wir wollen in diesem Stream wie eben
angekündigt vor allem auf die fehlende
Munition uns darauf konzentrieren aber
natürlich auch die Situation an der
Front nicht ganz aus dem Blick verlieren
wir hören von kleinen geländegewinnen
der Russen z.B bei avdka und bei bachmut
unter erheblichen Verlusten wie schätzen
Sie die Situation an der Front aktuell
ein
angespannt also ja die Russen greifen an
sie haben im Grunde in allen
Frontabschnitten die Initiative
die Verluste sind hoch aber natürlich
kostet das auch die Ukraine Kräfte und
vor allen Dingen Munition da ist die
Planungsunsicherheit das schwierigste
auf ukrainischer Seite man weiß nicht
wann weitere Lieferungen aus dem Westen
kommen aber man weiß nicht wie lange es
dauern wird das heißt man weiß auch
nicht wie man mit dem Gegenwert en
Bestand an Munition wie lange man
haushalten muss wie viel man jetzt
freigeben kann für
Sperrfeuer und
das ist natürlich aus ukrainischer Sicht
problematisch
aber Russland hat frische Kräfte in die
in die Offensive geschmissen und die
russische Offensive selber ist noch
nicht erschöpft also wir haben jetzt die
letzten zi D Tage ein bisschen ein
Nachlassen gehabt auch heute steigen die
Angriffe wieder das ist so das das
typische Verhalten wenn die Russen ihre
Truppen rotieren also alte abgenutzte
Kräfte rausziehen neue frische Kräfte äh
reinziehen und äh die diese Offensive
wird leider noch ein bisschen dauern
bevor sie abklinkt ä wenn es natürlich
so weitergeht mit den geländewinnen
werden sich die in Grenzen halten also
wenn den Russen kein Durchbruch gelingt
und es wird auch diese Offensive so
sicher nicht das ganze Jahr weitergehen
dazu sind die äh Menschen und
Materialverluste
schon zu hoch man hat in diesem in
diesem im Herbst in etwa schon die die
Neuproduktion oder
Gerät verloren dass in etwa der der
Produktion von ganz neuen Fahrzeugen des
ganzen letzten Jahres ähm
sozusagen wiedergibt das heißt man kann
es nicht natürlich solche solche
Angriffe nicht ewig durchhalten und
weiterführen es wird wieder ruhigere
Phasen geben aber das ist ja das
russische Kalkül dahinter man erhöht den
Druck auf die Ukraine man erhöht den
Druck auf den Westen
neues Gerät zu liefern und da sind ja
die Diskussionen kontroversiell und wenn
hier zu wenig ankommt dann kann dieser
Druck natürlich die Ukraine über lange
Zeit erdrücken Herr Kel ich habe
vorgestern an dieser Stelle mit dem
Sicherheits und Militärexperten nicoange
gesprochen der auch regelmäßig hier bei
uns zu Gast ist und der hat sinngemäß
gesagt die aktuelle die aktuelle
Strategie des Westens Waffen zu liefern
füre eben dazu dass sich die Ukraine mal
gut mal nur sehr lückenhaft gegen die
russischen Angriffe verteidigen kann
aber eben nicht entscheidend etwas
bewegen kann also salop formuliert zum
Verlieren zu viel zum Gewinnen zu wenig
entscheidet sich der Erfolg oder
Misserfolg der Ukraine in diesem Krieg
im
Westen zu einem gewissen Teil und zu
einem guten Teil auch ja leider also
wenn wir 2024 wir für die Ukraine ein
enorm wichtiges Jahr die Russen drücken
jetzt an das werden sie nicht das ganze
Jahr tun aber die Ukraine ist in der
Defensive nach der äh fehlgeschlagenen
Offensive im letzten Jahr muss man jetzt
viele leeren ziehen muss sich
rekonstituieren man hat einige Gedanken
was den Einsatz neue Waffensysteme neue
Störer angeht man hat auch einige
Gedanken wie man diese Geräte
effizienter einsetzt W man den Kampf
verbundenen Waffen
anders gestaltet mit stärkerem Fokus auf
drohen auf elektronische Kampfführung
besser besserer Synchronisation aber
vieles von dem da muss man eben rotieren
also Kräfte herauslösen äh den angepasst
an den neuen Verfahren ausbilden dann
wieder an die Front schicken
äh man muss an den eigenen Kommandanten
Arbeiten von denen man viele mobil
gemacht hat die aber ihre ihre
Offiziersausbildung ihre
Führungsausbildung noch in in ich würde
sagen der alten ukrainischen Armee also
noch stark sowjetisch geprägten
ukrainischen Armee gemacht haben da
gibt's eine lange todooliste die
natürlich die Ukraine auch selbst hat
aber der wen
ähm ist
ein erhebliches Teil in diesem Puzzle
und das betrifft erstens mal die
Ausstattung mit Material also was wir
liefern und das zweite ist natürlich wie
wir liefern da gab's zwei Schwachstellen
erstens wir haben das was und wie und in
welcher Quantität und in welchen
Rhythmus wir liefern immer als als
sozusagen als
innerallianzpitische Entscheidung
gesehen also Hausnummer stat a liefert
von einem gewissen Gerät fünf Stück dann
hat sich äh St hat B überlegt dann
liefere ich vom selben Gerät meiner
Größe und meinem politischen Wert
entsprechend dasselbe es gab bis jetzt
keine wirkliche arbeitsteilige
Belieferung man sagt okay aber du hast
in deiner Industrie die bessere
Möglichkeit diese Art von Gerät zu
liefern und auch zu erhalten und
sozusagen der andere Staat oder das
andere Land hat hat eine andere und wir
ergänzen das irgendwie so dass es für
die Ukraine ein rundes Bild zustande
kommt so ist ein Flickwerk zustande
gekommen aus verschiedensten Systemen
und das zweite ist man hat sich z viel
zu wenig Gedanken gemacht wie man diese
Systeme dann auch betreibt und erhält es
gibt unzählige Geschichten es gab ja
diese Leopard Geschichte zu wenig
einsatzfähig
es ist aber leider so dass dass das bei
viele Waffensysteme betrifft
panzerobizzen geliefert jetzt nicht die
panzerobitze 2000 für aber aber andere
ältere Modelle und es gibt keine
Ersatzrohre mehr dafür
die Rohre schießen sich aber mit der
Zeit aus lauter so Kleinigkeiten
wo man sich immer fragt ja was was haben
wir uns eigentlich dabei gedacht als als
das Zeug geliefert wurde es muss doch
klar sein dass wenn solche Geräte in ein
Kampfeinsatz gehen der Verschleiß äh
viel höher ist als wenn die jetzt beim
Ausbildungsplatz hier ihre ihre
standardrunden drehen und all all das
gibt es in Westen aufzuarbeiten wir
haben wir fangen jetzt erst an in der
Rüstungsindustrie jenseits von
Artilleriemunition größere Bestellungen
aufzugeben für Kampffahrzeuge für
Schützenpanzer für Kampfpanzer für
artilleriesysteme
ähm für solche Geräte dauert die
Produktionszeit zwei bis dre Jahre je
nachdem welches Gerät es ist
äh hätten wir zu Beginn des Krieges
schon damit angefangen dann hätten wir
jetzt ähm schon eine weit höhere anzeile
an Fahrzeugen die wir entweder in den
eigenen Streitkräften einführen und der
Ukraine äh älteres Gerät abgeben können
äh oder die wir direkt der Ukraine
zuführen könnten wenn wir es damals
getan hätten aber es wie gesagt die
meisten Politiker gingen davon aus dass
der Krieg äh bald vorbei sein werde und
dass so langfristige Maßnahmen sich
nicht lohnen werden äh weil sie zu spät
kommen und das straft uns jetzt
natürlich bitterlich weil wir jetzt
unsere reservelager was ein Gerät übrig
geblieben ist entweder aus der
Transformationszeit von sowjetisch
Warschau paktgerät zu NATO Standards
oder aus der Transformationszeit aus dem
Kalten Krieg heraus in die nächste
Fahrzeuggeneration äh diese altlage den
sind jetzt im Grunde aufgebraucht und
wir haben eigentlich keinen Plan und
keine Idee was dem nachfolgt und das
wird 2024 ein extrem schwieriges Jahr
sowohl für die Ukraine und auch für uns
deshalb wir können natürlich wenn wir
die Weichen schnell umlegen äh da noch
mal gegensteuern und zumindest die die
Grundlagen schaffen dass es der Ukraine
dann 2025 besser geht wenn wieder nichts
geschieht und wenn man wieder nur
diskutiert und das größte Produkt der
Europäischen Union heiße Luft sein wird
äh dann schaut's für die Ukraine in der
Tat bitte aus Herr gressel Helmut
Rosenberger hat uns eine Mail geschickt
und fragt was aus ihrer Sicht der Grund
dafür ist dass das Kanzleramt die
Lieferung von Taurus Marschflugkörpern
bisher
verweigert das ist eine sehr gute Frage
ähm da muss ich ehrlich sagen da bin ich
selber ein bisschen überfragt denn die
Gründe die ja dafür angegeben werden in
der Öffentlichkeit äh die stellen sich
alle als als Enden heraus also sowohl
die Frage des politischen Mandats stellt
sich im Grunde nicht weil ja die
Systemintegration also den Ukrainern zu
zeigen wie man das Ding verwendet und
wie man es an ihre Flugzeuge hängt und
technische Adaptionen dieser Flugzeuge
durch den Hersteller vorgenommen wird
und nicht durch die Bundeswehr also auch
die südkoreanischen oder die spanischen
taurusse wurden ja nicht durch die
Bundeswehr ausgeliefert und an
südkoreanische F15 gehängt
sondern sondern durch den her Hersteller
und das wäre natürlich auch im Falle der
Ukraine eine Frage für den Hersteller
das bereitzustellen
dass man Geodaten nicht herausrücken
kann ist auch so ein komisches Argument
also wir geben ja also der
Bundesnachrichtendienst gibt der Ukraine
ja schon klassifizierte Daten natürlich
sind Geodaten für ein daurus andere ein
anderes Format von klassifizierten Daten
aber wir haben ein Protokoll der Ukraine
klassifizierte Daten zu übergeben andere
natostaaten auch und
über die Geodaten kann man ja aus
Deutschland ja auch Steuern wo die Dinge
eingesetzt werden wenn ich der Ukraine
keine Geodaten zur Verfügung stelle über
das russische Kernland dann kann ich so
sicherstellen dass sie im Grunde nur in
den besetzten Gebieten verwendet werden
also da sozusagen äh widerspricht man
sich ja selber dann auch in der Angst
die Ukrainer könnte das einsetzen um um
Russland selbst anzugreifen
ähm ich muss ehrlich sagen ich verstehe
da den Kanzler nicht es gibt im in
Gesprächen mit anderen Leuten mit äh mit
Offizieren bzw mit äh Leuten die im
sicherheitsrelevanten Bereich arbeitet
oft andere Gründer die vorgenommen
werden der Taurus ist ja die einzige
deutsche
Fernwaffe mit der man in die russische
Tiefe wirkt im Falle eines Angriffs
Russlands auf die NATO deshalb gibt's
natürlich auch viele die
sozusagen gewisse Bedenken haben dass
man
den Taurus liefert erstens wegen den
Stückzahlen zweitens
weil weil die Russen da natürlich sehen
könnten wie das Ding funktioniert wie äh
wie sehr es
das Radar vom Radar gesehen oder nicht
gesehen werden welche Gegenmaßnahmen in
diesem
Flugkörper verbaut sind etc und das
könnte natürlich die Russen könnten da
natürlich dusus leerern ziehen äh das
ist ein valides Argument das leider
politisch überhaupt nicht auf den Tisch
gebracht wird weil es ja auch die
Lieferung von Taurus nicht um möglich
macht sondern in eine Debatte ein
betetten würde die jedes jeder Staat die
die Franzosen und die Briten ja auch für
sich führen müssen nämlich wenn ich das
Gerät liefer dann müsste ich eine
Neubeschaffung einleiten also Geräte
nachkaufen Deutschland by the way hat
hätte eigentlich der NATO weit mehr
Taurus zugesagt im Verteidigungsfall als
es derzeit betreibt das heißt wir müssen
eigentlich wenn wir die
natooverteidigung ernst nehmen jetzt
schon neue bauen und wenn wir neue bauen
können wir natürlich das unter
Bedingungen machen etwa von der Ukraine
verlangen dass Berichte über den Einsatz
an Deutschland geliefert werden dass
vielleicht deutsche Spezialisten auch
mit Messtechnik in die Ukraine reisen
dürfen um russische
fliegerabwehrtätigkeiten
zu beobachten oder Elektro elektronisch
auszuauschen damit man für den Taurus 2
oder für eine Weiterentwicklung des
Taurus dann auch valide Einsatzdaten hat
und man sieht ob die eigenen Konzepte äh
und Gegenmaßnahmen auch wirklich
funktionieren das
ist sozusagen wä auch eine charmante
Variante all diese verschiedenen
Varianten Optionen werden aber in
Deutschland überhaupt nicht diskutiert
das Kanzleramt grabt sich ein und sagt
im Grunde nichts und was in der
Öffentlichkeit und auf Twitter sonst so
durch die Gegend
erschwirt an Informationen ist
eher zum Kratzen und das ich habe das
glaube ich in einer Vergangenheit
vergangenen Sendung schon gesagt dass
unter unseren Alliierten also in London
in Paris führt das eher zu Verwirrung
weil die halt nicht verstehen können wo
Deutschland steht geht wenn es hier eine
offene Diskussion über die verschiedenen
strategischen Optionen gäbe dann würde
man selbst eine Nichtlieferung besser
verstehen können das kann man aber nicht
weil es keine Diskussion oder zumindest
keine ernsthafte gibt ja diesem
Unverständnis sind Sie nicht alleine das
schreibt z.B auch Frank K bei Youtube
das Kanzleramt will keine effektive
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine ist der
kommentar von Frank h Herr gressel in
der kommenden Woche wollen die
natostaaten in einer Sondersitzung mit
der ukrainischen Regierung über neue
mögliche Waffenlieferung beraten was
erwarten Sie konkret von diesem Treffen
und vielleicht daran noch angeschlossen
welche Waffensysteme Stichwort F16
Kampfjets könnten denn in diesem Jahr
für die Ukraine konkret im wahsten Sinne
des Wortes einen kriegsentscheidenden
Unterschied
machen ja einzelne
waachensysteme haben
kriegsentscheidenden Charakters immer
nur im Verbund die sie geliefert werden
F16 für die Ukraine enorm wichtig weil
ihre Kampflugzeuge sowjetischer Bauart
schon sehr abgenutzt sind das sind schon
alles ältere Flugzeuge und diese älteren
Flugzeuge wurden jetzt in den letzten
zwei Jahren wirklich sehr intensiv
geflogen das zweite ist dass die
Bewaffnung für diese Flugzeuge also V
allen die luftluftlenkwaffen die sie
verfeuern
fast alle in der in Russland hergestellt
werden zu einem gewissen Teil werden sie
auch in der Ukraine hergestellt aber nur
mit sehr geringer Kapazität und dass
deshalb die für diese Flugzeuge für
diese Kampfflugzeuge fehlt so ähnlich
wie das mit den mit der Kampfpanzer
Diskussion war wo sousagen russische
Kampfpanzer oder russische
Panzerverbände zwar sehr viele erbeutete
t72 und T80 aus der russischen Armee
haben aber das Problem war auf dem
Weltmarkt Munition für die Dinger zu
finden und genauso ist es mit den mit
den Fliegern ohne ohne ohne Munition
haben die halt noch begrenzten Wert und
deshalb braucht die Ukraine westliche
Kampfflugzeuge damit man auch westliche
Munition verschießen kann die erstens im
Westen noch vorhanden ist und zweitens
wo wir über die Produktionskapazitäten
verfügen das heißt für uns der Nachschub
berechenbarer und planbarer ist für die
Ukraine was sie verschießen kann was wir
liefern können als wenn man sich
irgendwo gebrauchte russische Raketen
auf dem Weltmarkt zusammenraffen muss
m es ist aber natürlich F16 nicht gleich
F16 die F16 die jetzt zugesagt wurden äh
die die sind auch ältere Modelle das
sind Geräte aus den 70er Jahren die in
den 90er Jahren noch ein bisschen
modernisiert wurden die haben auch
Radargeräte die nicht allzu weit reichen
die natürlich in einigen Punkten und
graduell besser sind als das was die
Ukraine jetzt verwendet
die aber was sowohl was die was die
Verwendung von luftluft als auch
luftbodenwaffen angeht nicht nicht
unbedingt die letzte Generation an an
Waffen verschießen werden können
ähm hier gab es vom Sprecher der
ukrainischen Luftwaffe eine Meldung dass
diese Geräte
modernisiert werden ich weiß jetzt aber
leider nicht genau was diese
Modernisierung betrifft ob das nur ein
Update ist von von
ein Check der der Rumpfe oder ob man sie
wirklich auch ein neues Radar oder
bessere Störsender bekommen
das das weiß ich leider Gottes selber
auch nicht aber es ist das Problem es
sind ältere Muster neuere Muster vor
allen Dingen aus den USA werden hier
natürlich besser das zweite ist ich habe
schon angesprochen für diese
Kampflugzeuge müssen wir Munition
bereitstellen das betrifft die gesamte
Allianz äh das Gute an der F16 ist dass
fast jedes Stück Munition das in der
NATO verschossen wird ähm für dieses
Fluggerät zertifiziert ist weil im
Grunde weil die meisten Staaten
dieses dieses Flugzeugmuster verwenden
zwar oft in moderneren Varianten aber
aber zumindest jeder und und
dementsprechend es
ähm äh sozusagen die Erfahrung hier gibt
aber muss ich natürlich dann auch einen
Plan zurechtlegen wer liefert was in
welcher Quantität und in welcher Dauer
und wenn der Krieg länger geht wie
beschaffen wir das nach wie produzieren
wir nach wie wie steigern wir die
Produktion damit wir das Gut ersetzen
und auch weiter liefern können und dazu
komme ich meine Erwartungen an äh das
nächste Ramstein Meeting wäre eine
vernünftige arbeitsteilige
Strategie zu entwickeln wie man die
Ukraine langfristig unterstützt es mir
sind diese ganzen politischen
Erklärungen bombastischen Erklärungen
wer jetzt was liefert und der versucht
sich gegenseitig zu übertreffen mit
irgendwelchen Ankündigungen mittlerweile
überhaupt nicht mehr recht weil die
Ankündigungen dann of ein Jahr brauchen
bis sie
verwirklicht werden lieber in den
Ankündigungen tiefstapeln aber
vernünftig arbeitsteilig Vorgehen nicht
nur in die in den eigenen hinter schauen
was man noch an Altgerät hat sondern
auch schauen was kann ich denn
produzieren was kann ich denn bauen wo
kann ich wo kann ich Ersatzteile liefern
welches System kann ich der Ukraine
helfen nachhaltig zu betreiben und dann
einen gemeinsamen Plan entwickeln wie
wir das in der Allianz dieser 50 Staaten
die hier von Munition bis zu schweren
Gerät alles mögliche liefern ein
vernünftigen Lieferplan durchkriegen das
wäre wirklich meine Erwartung und meine
Hoffnung für das nächste Ramstein
treffen Herr jetzt haben wir darüber
gesprochen was es bräuchte was die
Ukraine bräuchte an nachschuban
Lieferung und woran es fehlt was glauben
Sie denn das vielleicht noch
abschließend kurz womit wird die Ukraine
tatsächlich in naher Zukunft rechnen
können die F16 wden schon kommen also
die Pilotentraining ist schon relativ
weit fortgeschritten und das Fluggerät
gibt's auch
ich ich hoffe dass gerade der
kommissionsplan zur Beschaffung von
Artilleriemunition jetzt langsam Wirkung
zeigt also wie gesagt da wurde ja viel
Zeit damit verloren die genauen
Modalitäten zwischen den Mitgliedstaaten
auszuhandeln und der Kommission wer was
darf und wer was nicht darf aber im
September wurden die Verträge gemacht
und
Artilleriemunition braucht so in der
Regel 6 bis neun Monate bis man sie
produziert
das heißt das wird im Frühjahr
hoffentlich dann auf europäischeer Seite
Berg aufgehen
m mehr gepanzerte Kampf und
Gefechtsfahrzeuge insbesondere
Schützenpanzer würde ich mir wünschen es
gibt da gerüchtet dass noch ein paar
kommen werden
äh gepanzerte Fahrzeuge bei dem vor
allen Dingen was russischer Seite an
Artillerie verschossen wird ist es sind
enorm wichtig um Leute rein und raus aus
der Front zu bringen ä um äh Reserven
einsetzen zu können
und haben sich also gerade
Schützenpanzer mit einer halbwegst
tauglichen nachttauglichen Optik und
einer stabilisierten Maschinenkanone als
extrem wichtig er Wiesen
äh auch der deutsche mer obwohl er schon
älteres Semester ist ähm vielleicht
legen die Amerikaner noch ein scheufel
Bradl drauf das wä enorm wichtig